so
mars right yeah
you can roll
of course
so
okay
foreign
okay
i want to thank everybody who is joining
with us here today especially those who
are
behind me that i'll be talking more
about here
shortly to begin with let me point out
the obvious
evil
swept across
uvalde yesterday
anyone who
shoots his grandmother in the face
has to have evil in his heart
but it is
far more evil
for someone to
gun down little kids
it is intolerable and it is unacceptable
for us to have in the state anybody who
would kill little kids in our schools
children are a blessing
god teaches us that
they're filled with laughter
innocence
and joy
their love is a
gift that parents get to unwrapped every
single day
parents
in uvalde
had that gift
taken away from them
stolen
by a demented person
days before
days before yesterday
when these children
were at school
some were receiving awards
for perfect attendance
these kids
will never attend
school again
to say the least you validity has been
shaken to its core
families are broken apart
hearts
are forever shattered
all texans
are grieving with the people of uvalde
and people
are rightfully angry
about what has happened
events like this they tear at the fabric
of a community
our job
is to ensure that
the community is not going to be ripped
apart
all
texans must come together and support
the families who have been affected by
this horrific tragedy
what they need now more than ever
is our love
what they need is
uplifting
from all of our fellow texans and all of
our fellow americans
and let me emphasize something that
i know you all know
but the reality is as horrible as
what happened
it could have been worse
the reason it was not worse
is because
law enforcement officials
did what they do
they showed
amazing courage
by running toward gunfire
for the singular purpose of trying to
save lives
and it is a fact
that because
of their
quick response getting on the scene
being able to respond to the gunman and
eliminate the gunman
they were able to save lives
unfortunately
not enough
but i want to make sure that
everybody knows
all of the law enforcement agencies and
groups that are involved
and were involved
in this process
the texas rangers are leading the
investigation
and they are supported by the texas
department of public safety highway
patrol
the texas department of public safety
criminal investigative division
dps aircraft
dps intelligence counter and terrorism
division
dps crime and victim support
they're also supported by the texas
division of emergency management
the fbi as well as multiple federal
partners including the dea atf
hsi and border patrol
and then of course the valiant local
officials
the evaluating sheriff's department
the evaluated police department
uvalde independent school district
police
uvalde county constables
uvalde mayor the county judge
the valley district attorney's office
local public works and surrounding
police department
and the san antonio police and fire
department also
let me walk you through some of the
facts of what has happened
there's been a lot of things that have
been said some are correct some are
incorrect
let me tell you the best information
that we have at this time understanding
very importantly
that this is an ongoing investigation
and
ongoing investigations
often revealed new information
as those investigations progress
the first thing
that happened was
that
the gunman
shot his grandmother in the face
she then contacted police
the gunman fled and
as he was fleeing he had an accident
just outside of the elementary school
and he ran into the school
officers with the
consolidated independent school district
they approached the gunman and engaged
with the gunman
at that time
the gunman then entered a back door and
went down
two short hallways and then into a
classroom on the left hand side
the gun room
entered into that classroom and the
classroom was connected internally to
another classroom
border patrol
consolidated isd officers police
sheriffs and dps officers converged on
that classroom
and a border patrol officer
killed the gunman
as i said texas rangers are leading the
investigation joined by federal state
and local law enforcement officials
at this time we
know that
19 children
19 children
have lost their lives
two faculty members
lost their lives
in addition to that there are
17 people who are injured
but their injuries are not
life-threatening
all family members
of
all of these students and faculty
members
have been contacted informed about the
circumstances
officials are working with parents
to ensure that their parents are going
to be able to see their children
parents
should contact
victim services
at the county fairplex
we know that there are parents still
striving to make a connection
all parents
are welcome
and urged to
contact victim services at the county
fairplex
the gunman was 18
years old and
reportedly a high school dropout
reportedly
there has been no criminal history
identified yet
he may have had a juvenile record
but that is yet to be determined
there was no known mental health history
of the gunman
he used one weapon which was an ar-15
using 223 rounds
there was no
meaningful
forewarning
of this crime
other than what i'm about to tell you
as of this time the only information
that was known in advance
was posted by the gunman on facebook
approximately
30 minutes
before reaching the school
the first post was
to the point of
he said i'm going to shoot my
grandmother
the second post was
i shot my grandmother
the third post
maybe less than 15 minutes before
arriving at the school was
i'm going to shoot in elementary school
i mentioned that
during
the shootout that took place at the
school
in addition to
the students and the
faculty
there were three officers who were
injured who were all remain in good
condition
one deputy sheriff
lost a daughter
in that school
before coming out here we
had a long discussion
with law enforcement at all levels
we had a discussion with
community leaders elected officials
and
i asked
the sheriff
and others an a question
and got
the same answer from the sheriff as well
as from the mayor of evality
the question was
what is the problem here
and they were straightforward and
emphatic
they said
we have a mental
we have a problem with mental health
illness
in this community
and then they elaborated on
the magnitude
of the mental health challenges that
they are facing in the community and the
need
for more mental health support
in this region
i want to make sure everybody
understands
the mental health services that are
available at this time
with me making one clarifying point in
advance that i'm going to redouble down
in the aftermath
whenever anything
as shocking and extraordinary and
disturbing
as this event is occurs
there is an urgent need
for everybody affected
to access mental health
i cannot
be more emphatic than
saying
with great urgency
everybody in this community i mean
everybody
the victims the families
family members friends the the law
enforcement involved
but the entire community
is in utter shock
about this
some physical wounds that were sustained
by the officers they're going to
heal in the coming days
the mental and emotional wounds
are far harder to see
and last far longer
the state of texas working with federal
and local
officials and agencies
we're going to be here
for a long long time
and one
key point that we will focus on
is making sure that everybody in this
community
has the access they need for as long as
they need it
to address with the mental and emotional
health care needs
that they have
i want to list
various agencies and make sure
these are made available to the public
the mental health services currently
available are from
victim services from across the area
from federal state and local levels
including the family resource center at
the uvalde county fairplex
schools have crisis teams at the uvalde
civic center
they provide
wrap-around
services for families who are affected
the texas child mental health consortium
created by the state legislature in 2019
is available to assist
the blue bonnet children's advocacy
center available is available to provide
services for children
the texas health and human services
commission
is on site and will be available for
ongoing provision of services
the texas education agency is providing
supplemental counseling services
the texas department of public safety
counseling is providing counseling
services for law enforcement
and the fbi is also bringing in mental
health services for law enforcement
it could not be over emphasize the
importance
of law enforcement officers
all of them
seeking out and obtaining this mental
health counseling
the district attorney's office
for victim services
has a phone number available for
all victims and candidly the entire
community
in a way is a victim here
and i was provided their number to give
out to you publicly
this is the number for the district
attorney's office for victim services
the number is
830-278-2916
and at this time i will
pass the mic to lieutenant governor dan
patrick
excuse me
excuse me
excuse me
you're out of you're out of line and an
embarrassment
and you are doing nothing no he needs to
get his ass out of here this isn't the
place to talk to him this is totally
predictable
sir you're all alive
sure you are online i'm sir you are out
of line please leave this auditorium
i can't believe you're a sick son of a
[ __ ] that would come to a deal like
this to make a political issue
it's on [ __ ] like you why don't you
get out of here
foreign
[Music]
there are
there are family members
their family members
who are crying as we speak
their family members
whose hearts are broken
there's no words that anybody shouting
can come up here and do anything
to heal those broken hearts
we all
every texan
every american
has a responsibility
where we need to focus not on ourselves
and our agendas we need to focus on the
healing and hope
that we can provide to those who have
suffered unconscionable
damage to their lives and loss of life
we need all texans
to in this one moment in time
put aside personal agendas think of
somebody other than ourselves think
about the people who are hurt
and help those who have been hurt
and this time
lieutenant governor will speak
i was just about to say that
there will be plenty of time
to discuss and analyze
what happened yesterday
and do everything that we can within our
power
to hopefully
prevent
it from happening again
but now is a time
people watching around the world
in this country in this state to focus
on
these families as the governor
just said
right now we need to put our arms around
the families of these victims the
students and the teachers
this is not a partisan issue this is not
a political issue
this is an unimaginable
moment
that will impact the lives
of those who lost their children and
those who survived
the adults and the teachers the men and
women of law enforcement who were there
are better than this as a country
we are better than this
these these types of crimes when you see
children killed go to the very core of
all of us who have children or
grandchildren
we can't imagine the pain that these
families are going through
we saw it four years ago in santa fe
so can we not be a nation that can stand
together for at least
a day or a week or a month
my gosh
to put these families first
and everything else second
my gosh
you know we we we live in a time i said
this yesterday when people are at each
other's throats everywhere we turn
whether it's on the internet or an oscar
stage or two coaches arguing or in the
political world or the media world
who are we
as an american people who are we
we all have to do our part
all
do our part to make us a better people
and a better nation
evil will always walk among us
and in times like this i've seen it
the governor has seen it the speaker has
seen it the senators have seen it the
attorney general's seen it
in these other
shootings
sutherland springs el paso odessa santa
fe it's god that brings a community
together
it's god that heals a community
it's god that heals
a shattered and broken heart
and if we don't turn back as a nation to
understanding what we were founded upon
and what we were taught by our parents
and what we believe in
then these situations will only get
worse
it happened more often so
no matter what your thoughts are today
pray for these families pray for this
community
give us wisdom
give us wisdom but right now let's focus
on the families
they deserve that
they need our love they need our prayers
thank you governor
and now the speaker of the house david
phelan
thank you governor i appreciate it
mayor i'm sorry you had to
witness that outburst
now is not the time to politicize pain
and suffering
this time of year
should be the happiest time in a child's
life
summertime getting out of school
enjoying your family and your friends
and instead this
community is faced with an unspeakable
tragedy
of which there are no words there are no
words to
ease the pain and suffering the anger in
this community
i do want to reiterate what the governor
said about the mental health of this
community
this will take many many years
of pain and suffering and counseling
and your mental health is like any other
health it must be treated it must be
diagnosed it must be talked about
and
the legislature we reconvene we will
have a long very robust discussion about
mental health like we always have and
will continue to support mental health
in this state and especially rural
mental health
like the sheriff said like the mayor
said every community has mental health
needs and they must be addressed
and this crisis
is another iteration of mental health
crisis we have in this state
i also want to thank the law enforcement
for their work
dps border patrol sheriff's
police officers both locally in the
school district
i believe one school district's police
officer
his wife
in the shooting was there on the scene
and the governor mentioned
sheriff's deputy losing a child in that
building as well
this unspeakable
tragedy of this whole community and the
mental health of our law enforcement is
crucial in these times
and it's okay for them to say that
something's wrong as well
i do my deer hunting here in uvalde
county
it's a beautiful community with
beautiful people
and all we can say is how tragic this is
and
the support this the state
will show
and will continue to show
and
we we just appreciate your resiliency
and let us know how we can help the
state of texas
thank you and now the director of the
texas department of public safety steve
mccraw
thank you governor
on behalf of the sheriff chiefs of
police the department's been asked to go
through a timeline of the facts as we
know the investigation right now is
preliminary this information but we'll
provide as much information as we can
first as already reported you know
salvador romas ramos was responsible for
the horrific attack and killing of 19
school-aged children
and two adults
he's 18 years old as previously reported
he was dropped out of school he had no
criminal history that we've been able to
find and detect at this particular point
he lived with his grandmother
celia
who is 66 years old
on march 17th ramos purchased a
semi-automatic rifle at a local sporting
goods store on march 18th he purchased
375 rounds of ammunition for that rifle
on march 20th he purchased another
semi-automatic rifle at that same local
store
the fbi has been able to
find information on his facebook account
that the governor had he provided new
information on at 11 approximately 11
o'clock he announced you know on
facebook a post a message that he was
going to shoot his grandmother
he shot his grandmother he re-reported
that he had shot her and after that he
reported that he was going to a school
to attack it he didn't identify the the
specific school he did say elementary at
that point in time
but the timeline is anywhere from 11 to
11 to 11 30. his mother reported him to
the police department when she was able
to run across the street to a neighbor
and get help and she was medevaced to
san antonio in critical condition at
this point but she's still alive
the subject ramos at that point in time
used her vehicle his grandmother's
vehicle he was living at their residence
since march of 20 of 2022
used her vehicle to drive approximately
2.2 nine miles which is about a block
and a half away from
the school
rob elementary school he crashed the
vehicle at that point in time he exited
the exit with a backpack he took a rifle
with him
one rifle it was a daniel defense that
he had previously purchased that had
mentioned
he went towards the
the west side of the campus which is a
back door
but as he was approaching as the
governor mentioned earlier there was a
brave consulting independent school
district resource officer that
approached him
engaged engage them
and at that time there was not gunfire
was not exchanged
but the subject was able to make it into
the
into the school as the governor reported
he went down a hallway turned right then
turned left and there were two
classrooms that were adjoining and
that's where the carnage began
as he was shooting when the shooting
began
we had uvalde police officers arrive on
scene along with the consolidated
independent school district officers
immediately breached because we know in
officers every seconds of life
they breached it engaged the the the
active shooter
and continued to keep them pinned down
in that location
you know after words until after a
tactical team could be put together
comprised of border patrol agents on the
front end some members of their board
attack unit which is a swat team for
border patrol also there was a zavala
county deputy that got into the stack
and two uvalde police officers they
breached the classroom door they went in
they engaged ramos and killed them at
the scene
that covers the governor one thing i'd
like to say though when you hit a little
head is that
you and the profession of law
enforcement is a profession you know
what rooks looks right and how we
measure ourselves is the absence of
crime and disorder
obviously this is a situation we failed
in the sense that we didn't prevent this
mass attack
but i can tell you those officers that
arrived on the scene and put their lives
in danger they saved other kids they
kept them pinned down and we're very
proud of that at the same time we're
always looking to get better and look at
anything that might have been out there
we've yet to find a clue whether social
media
or other indicators that might have
given us any type of idea that he was
about to do something like this it gives
an opportunity to prevent it because as
we know the overriding priority of you
certainly the legislature and texas and
the people of texas is that is that it's
all about prevention you know prevent
the next mass attack and thank you for
your leadership and speaker and
lieutenant governor thank you
thank you and now the superintendent for
the consolidated independent school
district hal harrell
thank you governor thank you for being
here today thank you for your support
i appreciate your team coming and
speaking to us
and providing the services and resources
that you have
as superintendent i could never imagine
a day like yesterday
end of school
award ceremonies
the time of a third second third or
fourth
graders life at that point
it was a senseless
and tragic event and this magnitude our
community
is
is heartbreaking it really is
we have had
a lot of support here from our community
surrounding counties surrounding
districts and all over the state and i
appreciate you
for
thinking of us and sending that support
i have to
relay the heartbreak of our teachers at
rob campus i met with them this morning
but as i looked across that room there
was a group of heroes
in that room
if it weren't for them along with
the law enforcement came
that were willing to
cradle their kids get them out of the
classroom
when it was safe when they were guided
and the trust our kids had in their
teachers
that uh
that says volumes for our staff here in
uvalde they are heroes
they uh did heroic things yesterday and
they are always very humble but they are
truly humble heroes yesterday we lost
two teachers
these two teachers
i would say are the cornerstone of that
campus to some great degree there are
two beautiful souls they have taught on
that campus for many years they have
kids in our district
and they pour their heart and soul into
what they did in educating our kids in
uvalde
19 students 19 precious students who
came to school yesterday
to enjoy the day to enjoy the award
assembly
and as i look at their pictures you can
just tell by their angelic smile
that they were
loved
that they loved coming to school
and they were
just precious individuals
this is a difficult time for everybody
we are hurting
we're
we have been cut deep here in our
community
we will move forward it's going to take
some time moving forward
our faith has been shaken
we ask you to continue to pray for these
families these kids
in our community and our teachers
i am a product of you value i'm born and
raised here i've worked for this
district for 30 years
i never thought i would be sitting in
front of you doing this today
but please pray for our teachers
pray for our community
and we will move forward
thank you governor thank you
we'll take a few questions
so the the ability of an 18 year old to
buy a long gun
has been in place in the state of texas
for more than 60 years
and
think about during the time over the
course of that 60 years
we have not had episodes like this
and why why is it that for the majority
of those 60 years
we did not have
school shootings
and why is it that we do now
the reality is i don't know the answer
to that question
however
what i do know in in talking to the
leaders here
as well as leaders in other locations
around the state
and that is one thing that has
substantially changed
is the status of mental health in our
communities
what i do know is this
and that is
we as a state we as a society
need to do a better job with mental
health
anybody
who shoots somebody else
has a mental health challenge
period
we have we as a government
need to find a way
to
target that mental health challenge and
do something about it
director mccraw will have the best
information on that
we're in the process of doing the crime
scene right now first one being the
school the second being the the vehicle
and the third the grandmother's
residence i can tell where it's a
detailed process so i can't answer that
but for right now we believe that all
the children were shot and killed
by the
ramos
uh
we did see some and and i think one was
of a concern and that concern was
you know relayed to allegedly we haven't
confirmed it yet to someone in
california who didn't report it and we
in the process of working with the fbi
right now to make sure she's interviewed
and find out more about it there may be
other clues out there right now that
we're not aware of this is a preliminary
part of the investigation we're going to
scour everything to find anything that
what could have indicated in some way
shape or form that this individual was a
threat to the community
none none at all
in fact this is you know we're astounded
as the beginning of investigation
because there's usually something out
there but right now
it is as that report on the timeline if
we find out something else we'll provide
that information
so i'm going to answer in part but we
also have the ta commissioner mike
morath with us who may be able to shed
additional light but here here's the
information that we know and you you
pointed out
uh sb11 listen as you know
but others may not people need to
understand
that in the aftermath of the santa fe
shooting
i signed 17 laws
to address school safety
and one of them dealt with threat
assessment and preparation for threat
assessment and there are certain
standards that
schools are required to comply with
to make sure that they are
addressing threat assessments
i have no information as we speak at
this partic particular time about the
status of this particular elementary
school or the isd about what the status
was concerning threat assessments
however uh to make sure that your
broader question is answered
sufficiently
mike you want to come up this
the person coming up
is mike morath who is the commissioner
for the texas education agency
so there's significant appropriations
provided to
ensure that the local school systems
around the state have resources for this
one of the components of senate bill 11
was a school safety allotment there was
additional upfront funding for that
the texas school safety center and our
agency work in collaboration to provide
technical assistance and training to
school district leaders counseling team
leaders others to ensure that the
threat assessment protocols and these
procedures
including
threat response plans of the operational
multihazard plans are practiced on a
recurring basis so
there have been essentially
fairly significant efforts to bolster
those managerial practices and these
detective or preventative practices in
schools all over the state of texas
we will continue to do more
after any incident like this of course
you
reflect on lessons learned
to to
ensure that we can prevent this kind of
a situation
in schools
um
going forward
if i can if i can just add one one sec
i'll call on you next one second if i
can just add to that briefly in 19 the
house and senate worked together
put a hundred million dollars into
uh trying to
give the schools all the tools that they
needed to try and
protect the students
the marshals program the guardian
program to arm teachers where schools
want it
we left a lot of those programs optional
off to the parents and the school boards
and the school districts and
and they're doing the best they can
and
you're always going to have
again no matter what you do there's
going to be someone to find another area
that's vulnerable but
the legislation legislature did act the
governor signed those bills but we can
and need to do more in the area of
mental health
we've also been working on that as well
but need to do more
we've got to in our smaller schools
where where we can get down to one
entrance
um
one entrance might be one of those
solutions
if you had taken three more minutes to
find an open door
police were there pretty quickly but
this school district has been doing a
really good job
in trying to protect their students and
those teachers
died
yesterday protecting their students and
this is a continued work for us
so first with regard to yesterday
i was
actually in taylor county
responding to a different disaster a
disaster of
fires that had
ripped through taylor county and
destroyed 20 homes and that is when i
learned
about
the shooting that was taking place
pretty much at that time
here
on the way back to austin
i stopped and let people know
that i could not stay that i needed to
go
and i wanted them to know what happened
and
get back to austin so that i could
continue my collaboration with texas law
enforcement to make sure that all the
needs were being met
here in the uvalde area
as far as future plans are concerned
listen
unlimited living moment to moment right
now
my heart my head and my body are in
uvalde right now
and i'm here to help the people who are
hurting
i can't
it's going to be within within a minute
like 40 minutes or something with an
hour but i don't want to give you a
particular timeline
but bottom line is that law enforcement
was there
they did engage immediately they did
contain them in the classroom and they
put the tactical stack together you know
in a very orderly way and of course
breached and assaulted the individual
the initial engagement
no i mean it was just yeah it couldn't
be confronted him and and wanted to find
out because he was through the report
heard the accident was out trying to
check on that particular crash when he
saw it so he followed him right in
immediately okay and when rounds were
exchanged and of course then also we had
two uvalde police officers briefly
described that went in and was involved
in also the shooting with the subject
and were wounded and of course they were
also responsible for containing in that
area
go ahead
yes sir
the further
well i don't know where he was in the
community but obviously in the uvalde
area because they got there so quickly
and in force and of course i'll let them
answer that question but they uh they
were there in force and of course they
were importantly they had some members
of their tactical team there on the
vortech team and they took the lead on
that stack but i'll defer to i think i
have a border patrol uniform
okay so first off the u.s border patrol
del rio sector has a station in uvalde
so we have about 150 or so agents that
are permanently assigned to uvalde we
also have several agents in other
stations that choose to live here in
this community as well so we had folks
that came from off duty we had folks
that came from training we had folks
that were in the field and responded so
a multitude some 80 and total mortality
agents responded so as to where that
particular individual came from don't
have that yet the investigation will
bear out but we have a large presence
permanently here in uvalde
the juke
not going to release his name just yet
go ahead
we begin talking about it in there i'll
just tell you one one thing that we
talked about which is
something we've heard in some other
regions of texas also and and that is in
approximately a
maybe as much as a a 40 county region
around the area where we gather right
now
there is
no mental health hospital
and there is a shortage of beds
for mental health in this region if
someone is suicidal if someone has a
mental health problem
they oftentimes would have to go to
someplace like san antonio
and
with the growing population in this
region with
the
profound mental health challenges that
were
discussed with us
one takeaway i had
was that there is greater need for a
physical
mental health care facility
in this region
but we know that the buildings don't
treat people people treat people
and so there there needs to be
more personnel
more strategies
a greater understanding by the mental
health care provider community about
what the needs are and they will be best
equipped to know the best way to provide
or let's say meet those needs bottom
line is this
and that is i think it's a fair
statement
that
legislative leaders understand
about health challenges in the more
rural settings in the state of texas and
we have a genuine commitment to help
address those mental health care
challenges
it's one of those issues that
was widely discussed
in the last several sessions
in particular in the 2019 session
and
pretty much every issue
was raised by
one legislator or another
about potential ways to address
shootings like this
and
the consensus
arose around those 17 bills that i did
sign that they hardened schools they
made schools safer they addressed mental
health
and issues like that were the solutions
that were agreed upon
by legislators at that time
and that is going to be the similar
approach that i perceive
legislators will continue to focus on
we we
we consider that what we did in 2019
to be one of the most profound
legislative sessions not just in texas
but we've seen in any state in
addressing school shootings that said to
be clear
we all understand
our work is not done
our work must continue
and we will continue to discuss with
legislators about all the potential
avenues and pathways that we can take to
make sure that schools will be even
safer going forward
and i know people like to try to
oversimplify this
uh
let's talk about some real facts
and and that is there are
quote
real
gun laws
in chicago
there are quote real
gun laws in new